the very first white card in football
history was was put out by referee and
I'd never heard of a white card before
apparently this is a new car usually I
think referees get the red card and the
yellow card but now they have a white
card as well at least for FIFA and
Portugal and the white card was designed
uh to show recognition to clubs for acts
of fair play during the match in a bid
to improve ethical value in the sport so
what happened was one of the players got
injured and the medical staff from both
teams came out to try to help the
injured player and so the referee put up
the white card to say basically good job
but it doesn't seem to have any
implications like the red card and the
yellow card means something the white
card is basically the referee saying
good job
I'm confused if you know about the white
card or you love the white card or think
it's crazy let me know all you crazy
football fans tell me your thoughts put
in the comments below